JAMES DRISCOLL: Hey, everybody.
I'm James Driscoll,
and I'm really, really
excited to welcome
a really great--
or one of my favorite musicians,
a talented artist, and also
a winemaker.
So if you can help me
welcome Brett Dennen.
[APPLAUSE]
BRETT DENNEN: Thank you.
Welcome, everybody [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks for having me.
I'm gonna play a few songs, and
then we're gonna talk a little.
AUDIENCE: Yay.
[LAUGHTER]
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
BRETT DENNEN: Sound good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRETT DENNEN: Does anybody
here know my music?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRETT DENNEN: OK.
[SINGING "SHE'S MINE"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[SINGING "SAN FRANCISCO"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Everything is good?
[LAUGHTER]
I can take requests if
you-- if there's songs.
But I may shut it down, if I--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Play "Sydney?"
BRETT DENNEN: Yeah,
I could do "Syd."
Maybe I save it
for the last song.
AUDIENCE: Oh, right, right.
[LAUGHTER]
BRETT DENNEN: Put it on hold.
AUDIENCE: You probably don't
have it ready, but [INAUDIBLE]?
BRETT DENNEN: That's--
I'll shut that one down.
Do you have a second?
AUDIENCE: "Ain't No Reason?"
BRETT DENNEN: OK.
We'll do that.
I know that one.
[LAUGHTER]
[SINGING "AIN'T NO REASON"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I think I can do a couple more.
AUDIENCE: Can you do
"When We Were Young"?
BRETT DENNEN: Sure can.
"When We Were
Young" and "Sydney."
Do I have two more?
A couple more?
Or whatever?
JAMES DRISCOLL: As many
as you can give us.
BRETT DENNEN: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES DRISCOLL: Two is good.
BRETT DENNEN: Two is good.
All right.
JAMES DRISCOLL: How
about "Make You Crazy"?
BRETT DENNEN: Three?
Three more?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Well, I promise I'm not a poser.
I know it's not raining
or muddy outside,
and I'm wearing these
shoes because I'm
going to Utah after this, so.
And these are the only
shoes I brought on the trip.
In case you were wondering
why is he wearing
duck boots in Mountain View.
[LAUGHTER]
That's why.
OK.
Well I'm gonna play
these three more,
and then we're gonna
do something fun.
Yeah?
[SINGING "WHEN WE WERE YOUNG"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[SINGING "MAKE YOU CRAZY"]
It's your turn to
sing something here.
[LAUGHTER]
[GUITAR MUSIC]
Anybody?
No?
I'll do something.
[SINGING]
All right, help me out.
Woah.
Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
[SINGING]
Try it again.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
BRETT DENNEN: [SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We'll do one more.
And then something
fun will happen.
Involving talking and wine.
OK.
[SINGING "SYDNEY"]
Sorry, there's a part
you guys sing there.
You say, [SINGING]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
BRETT DENNEN: [SINGING]
For some reason, I
sing the chorus better
when somebody, or a bunch of
people, are singing that part.
[LAUGHTER]
So please, the next time around.
[SINGING "SYDNEY"]
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
BRETT DENNEN: [SINGING]
(WHISPERING) I come running.
[SINGING]
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
BRETT DENNEN: [SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Thank you.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So I had
the pleasure of meeting you
a couple months ago--
BRETT DENNEN: Yes.
JAMES DRISCOLL: at your
wine release party.
BRETT DENNEN: In Napa.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Napa, yeah.
And the first question that I
asked you when I had the chance
was, of the songs that
you've written, which
is your personal favorite.
And without any hesitation, you
said "There Is So Much More."
Has it changed, or
is it still that?
BRETT DENNEN: That's
probably-- yes.
I think I'm-- I don't know
if favorite is the right way
for me to describe it.
I think it's the song that
I'm most pleased with myself
for writing.
And I apologize, because
I didn't play it, but--
JAMES DRISCOLL:
That's fine, but I was
hoping you could talk about it.
BRETT DENNEN: I have--
yeah, I have-- so the song
doesn't have any chorus, but I
still think it's a good song.
And it's not really clear
what the song is about,
but I still think it's
a really good song.
And the song is
kind of monotonous,
but it's still very
good in my opinion.
And I think, for
all those reasons,
I had a song without a chorus,
that is kind of sleepy,
that you're not really
sure what's going on,
it's about a lot of
things lyrically.
But it still comes across as
a good song, and it's subtle
and it's simple.
And as an artist,
I'm always trying
to find the best way to
say the most with the least
amount of words and
chords and time,
but still evoke some sort of
emotion and make people think.
And whatever it was
I was going through
or whatever I was
going for, I did it.
And it's the only time
I've done it so well.
Does that make sense?
JAMES DRISCOLL: Yeah.
BRETT DENNEN: OK.
JAMES DRISCOLL: One other
thing I was thinking about.
So a while back, you
toured with John Mayer.
BRETT DENNEN: Uh-huh.
JAMES DRISCOLL: And he was
talking about your music
and he said that you paint
landscapes with your music.
And I was thinking about that
in the context of where you
are when you write your music.
And I know that-- I think you
retreated to the mountains
to work on an album,
and now you live
near the ocean in Venice Beach.
So how does the
landscape influence
the music that you write and
the albums that you work on?
BRETT DENNEN: Well
I think he was
referring to just the imagery.
I-- like, my favorite writers
are the ones who don't just
say, like, I love you,
but they'll say I love you
and this is what's happening
around me while I'm telling you
I love you.
And this is-- you know,
there's-- here are the sights
and sounds and smells.
And give you some sort of
imagery to help not only,
like, give you something to
think about and set the mood,
but also give you a
sense of place and time,
and even let the imagery
tell some of the story.
But landscape
literally has a lot
to do with the songs I write.
Indirectly, just I can't-- I
have a hard time writing songs
in a city.
I used to be able to
write songs on the road
or in New York or San Francisco
or wherever with ease, just
because I could tap into
the creative energy,
or whatever's happening in the
city that's kind of pulsating,
and grab images from
what I see all around me.
But it got harder and harder for
me to do that over the years,
and now what I need is quiet.
And I need a place
like the mountains
or the desert or
the ocean where it's
like I'm staring out into some
form of a vast expanse which
allows me to turn a little
more inside and focus.
And I need quiet.
And I usually need a
transitional season.
The list is getting longer.
It's gotta be quiet,
it's gotta be beautiful,
it's gotta be open,
it's gotta have
some sort of strong landscape
energy, like a mountain.
I have to be sad.
It has to be, like, a
transitional season like autumn
or spring.
Usually wine is involved.
JAMES DRISCOLL: But do you find
if you're out in the desert,
do you-- are you more likely to
write a sad song than if you're
near the ocean and
you hear the waves?
Then you might have a
little bit more beat.
Something a little bit more--
BRETT DENNEN: Yeah,
I think totally.
Well I think the most
introspective songs
I write come from
being in the desert.
And I think being
around an ocean
is-- makes me-- ocean's a
different kind of energy.
And there's all those ions
exploding all around me
that make me feel good.
So ocean, I would say, or
a river or a waterfall,
would make me feel a
little more upbeat.
The mountains, though,
is strong kind of
like we've been here
forever stoic energy
that-- I don't know
what that does to me.
JAMES DRISCOLL: As you were
describing those things,
I got-- I don't
know about you guys,
but I got all these crazy images
in my head of, like, Brett
playing music on top of a
mountain or in a waterfall.
Like I know that doesn't
make any sense, but what does
it look like when you write?
Like, do you scribble
on the back of a napkin?
Do you write on your phone?
Are you, um, in the bathroom?
BRETT DENNEN: It's
hard for me to talk
about writing because sometimes
writing is just going to work,
just sitting down and
forcing yourself to write.
And then sometimes writing
is catching inspiration like
it's some kind of a unicorn or
something that you don't really
believe in, but you
don't-- it's here,
all of a sudden it's here
and you're really inspired.
And you're just trying to
capture the moment with a net
or something like that.
Or the net being whatever
tools-- whatever chords
you know or words you know.
Sometimes songs come from
just months and months
of writing on a
computer, a laptop,
or scribbling down
lyrics and poems
and trying to find a
way to put it to music.
Sometimes song-- like you're
messing around on a guitar
and you have a
progression or a melody,
and you're like what sort
of words go with this.
And sometimes you
put the two together.
Sometimes you slave over it.
Sometimes it comes like that.
You never really know.
That's why people
who know me and know
that when I have to write, I
disappear for a while because I
torture myself a
little bit, a lot.
And I don't feel good about
myself unless I write.
It's not healthy,
but it works for me.
JAMES DRISCOLL: I'm glad
you brought that up,
because we were talking before
your performance about what
you're working on right now
and where you are right now.
And I think there's an
album coming out in May?
BRETT DENNEN: Yes.
JAMES DRISCOLL: That I think
we're all pretty excited about.
But you're still working on it.
And you said that you've
finished with the recordings,
but there are songs that
are going to have to be cut
and there are songs that are
gonna have to be re-ordered.
Can you talk about
where you are right now
in terms of your work?
BRETT DENNEN: The
album is finished.
We're-- the recording is done,
and I'm pretty happy with it.
I think it's, for who I am
as a person and an artist
and my process and the
craft that I've developed
as a writer and the
things that I want to say,
I feel very confident
in what I've done.
We're just figuring
out how to release it.
And that could be
the marketing, that
could be the album
packaging isn't done yet.
You know, when you put-- it's--
the way the industry is now is
artists like myself, we put
albums out every three, two,
sometimes four to five years.
So you really have to go
in with a lot of confidence
when you're putting it out
there, and stand behind it.
And we're just trying to figure
out the best way to do that,
because I really want
people to hear it
and I want it to get noticed
and I want to engage my fans,
but I also want to
reach out to new people.
And so it may sound easy,
like oh, you just put it out
and you sing your heart
out and it's great,
but there's like
all kinds of things
that you have to consider,
like what's the label releasing
at that time.
Is there gonna be
competition with this.
When should we tour.
How, like, what's-- so that's
what we're figuring out,
that boring stuff.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So
boring stuff aside, I'm
curious about your
intention, like specifically
if there's one intention that
you have when you play music,
and especially when you
share it at a concert.
Your shows can create a
really intimate environment
with the audience.
And so I'm wondering, from
your perspective-- I'm sure
you have several intentions,
but what's the one overriding
intention that you have when you
share your music with people?
When you play at a show?
BRETT DENNEN: It's
just, simply put,
I want to make people feel good.
The way I want to
make them feel good
is I want to be open and
vulnerable and sensitive
in the songs I write and
the way that I play them.
And I hope that it
allows people to hear
the song with an
open heart and feel,
maybe go through some emotions
at the end of the concert
or at the end of the album,
come out of it feeling good.
I may be dreaming,
but I would really
love if people tapped
into their own--
whatever they're going
through, their own
struggles, and feel
good about themselves,
beyond just feeling good.
I want to give people hope
and make them cry and dance
and just feel good about life.
Comfortable with themselves.
Because those are all
things that I struggle with,
and sometimes I want to make
a sad song or a sad album
or an angry song
or an angry album,
but I can't-- it never seems
to happen because I want to put
something positive out.
Even if it comes from
a place of sadness,
I just want to,
simply put again,
to make people feel good.
And feel like they're on drugs.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES DRISCOLL: The
legal ones, right?
Um, thinking about that.
So--
BRETT DENNEN: By
acting like I'm stoned,
then I make people,
like, feel high.
JAMES DRISCOLL: You
did drink a lot of tea
before the performance.
BRETT DENNEN: I did.
I was dragging.
JAMES DRISCOLL:
About like four cups.
BRETT DENNEN: It's gonna
kick in any minute.
JAMES DRISCOLL:
Well I also noticed
that it seems like
a lot of your songs
are about heartbreak and
the healing afterwards.
And I was kind of wondering
about that in terms of,
like, what are
the saddest lyrics
you think you've ever written?
BRETT DENNEN: I've written a
lot about death and loss, that
is for sure.
And then heartbreak
romantically,
and just through
letting go and change,
and just the different
waves and ripples and things
in life that are
hard to navigate.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Is
there a single line
that, when you sing it,
it breaks your heart
a little bit every time?
You guys know his music.
There's a lot of
heartbreak in it.
AUDIENCE: He's having
an Oprah moment.
[LAUGHTER]
BRETT DENNEN: Well I'd
have to think about it.
JAMES DRISCOLL:
Or how about this.
Is there a line that always
brings you a lot of happiness,
that's always
positive, that always
resonates with the audience?
BRETT DENNEN: Yeah.
Well one of the songs
I played recent-- here,
when I was over
there, was a song
called "When We Were Young."
And there's a line in
there about high school
being a failure factory.
And I don't do it
that often, but that's
like-- makes me feel good,
because I feel like I'm
sticking it to somebody.
You know?
And then I also feel that
most people can relate
to that in one way or another.
It might not have
been high school,
but maybe like on a
social economic level
they could be like yes, high
schools are failure factories.
He is right.
Or they can be like yeah, nobody
understood me in high school.
I like singing that one.
That's the one that
makes me feel good.
JAMES DRISCOLL: OK.
Cool.
I only have a couple
more questions,
but we do have a mic
for audience questions
if there's anything that
you wanted to ask Brett.
But the first of two
questions I have for you,
so this is really random and
awkward-- I apologize ahead
of time-- but you have
a line that I really
like in the song "Who
Do You Think You Are."
I think it's "there's a homeless
man sleeping in the parking
lot.
I wonder what he dreams about."
And so I'm wondering,
you're a musician,
do musicians hear
music in their dreams?
BRETT DENNEN: Yes.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Could
I get some of that?
BRETT DENNEN: You want some
of my dreaming music, or--
JAMES DRISCOLL: I don't
have any music in my dreams.
And I think if I had music in my
dreams, they'd be a lot better.
BRETT DENNEN: You never
hear music in your dreams?
JAMES DRISCOLL: No,
I've been trying to.
BRETT DENNEN: Even like
a song that you know,
like "Going To The Chapel"?
I don't know why I
said that one, but.
That never come-- like a
song that you know and love,
like if you--
JAMES DRISCOLL: I
would love that.
BRETT DENNEN: It's
never happened.
JAMES DRISCOLL: No.
BRETT DENNEN: Wow.
Do you see colors?
JAMES DRISCOLL: I don't know.
BRETT DENNEN: Do you smell?
JAMES DRISCOLL: I hope so.
BRETT DENNEN: You fly?
JAMES DRISCOLL: Yes.
BRETT DENNEN: Do other people
hear music in their dreams?
Yeah.
JAMES DRISCOLL: He's a musician.
BRETT DENNEN: And you've
come-- you've heard something
that you wrote in a dream,
and you woke up and found it
on whatever instrument you play?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
BRETT DENNEN: Yeah.
It's-- I don't know what it is,
but I know when you play music
you're constantly creating
pathways in your brain
for melodies.
And melodies are
everywhere, too.
I mean, I may come up with
some brilliant melody,
and then realize
that it's not mine,
it's in a thousand other
songs and it's not--
it may still be brilliant,
but I didn't come up with it.
Melodies, they're already
in our subconscious.
They're all around us.
And dreaming definitely
taps into everything
that's around us that we're not
aware of, especially emotions,
things that we
didn't know-- don't
know that we are
feeling or haven't felt
or are ignoring or repressing.
But I don't remember
my dreams that much.
JAMES DRISCOLL: But you remember
that there's music in it.
BRETT DENNEN: Yeah.
JAMES DRISCOLL: That's cool.
BRETT DENNEN: Well,
yeah, sometimes.
Sometimes I'll wake up
with a melody in my head
that came from a dream.
And I'll turn it into something.
Actually it happened in a song
I wrote for this new record,
but it didn't make
it on the new record.
So it's an endless--
it's a pointless story.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So
the last question
that I had has to do with partly
how you came to be here today.
So you--
BRETT DENNEN: Wine.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Wine?
Yeah.
Your business partner, Ian,
was interested in promoting
the new label.
Beautiful label, I know that
you did the artwork for it.
And it's a delicious wine,
too-- Charismatic Fool.
And so Ian wanted to
have a wine tasting here,
and I thought yeah, that sounds
great, but can Brett come
and can he bring his guitar
and can he play and talk
and can we get everything
out of him that we could.
So hopefully we have.
BRETT DENNEN: What'd he say?
Yes or no?
JAMES DRISCOLL: Yeah, he--
[LAUGHTER]
You're here, so
it all worked out.
But wine-making was interesting.
So you're accomplished
as a musician,
you're accomplished
as a painter,
and now you're making wine.
How did that happen,
and how's it going?
BRETT DENNEN: Well my
friends Ian and Steve have
a business where they get
artists such as myself who they
think have somewhat of-- some
sort of lifestyle brands,
but also have a love of wine
and an interest in making wine.
Because I don't know
how to make wine.
I'm learning through them.
And so we get together and we
talk and we dream up an idea
and they say, like, if you
were going to make a wine,
what would it be?
And I say, a rose.
And they say, huh, OK.
How are we going
to make this work?
What about a sparkling rose?
And then we start tasting wine.
And they work with
an actual winemaker,
and they buy grapes or juice,
and everybody gets involved.
And I just paint the label
and drink a lot a wine.
And it's a
collaborative process,
but that I can't take credit
for other than the fact
that I feel like
it's collaborative,
but the wine comes
out tasting like me.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES DRISCOLL: Can
you describe that?
What do you taste like?
AUDIENCE: Rose.
BRETT DENNEN: Well, it's rose.
It looks-- it's the
same color as my hair.
And it's elegant and
graceful, but most of the time
it's bubbly and-- it's
all about celebrating,
but it has its moments
of being graceful.
We went down this
road with a sparkling
rose because we wanted a wine
that was all about celebration,
but we wanted to make it
very approachable and easy
drinking so that every day
could be a celebration.
You don't have to wait until
New Year's or your birthday
or whatever.
It's at a price point
that's affordable so
that you could just make
tonight or today or this morning
or whenever, the
bathtub or the shower,
a celebration, and just
feel good about-- again,
feel good about life.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Well you being
here I think makes a lot of us
feel pretty good about life.
So thanks for that performance.
BRETT DENNEN: Yes.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Are there
any audience questions?
BRETT DENNEN: You're welcome.
JAMES DRISCOLL: I think there's
a microphone, too, running
around.
BRETT DENNEN: Ooh.
Attached to a person.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for coming, Brett.
You described how you
want, in your shows,
you want your audience to feel
good not just in the moment,
but feel good about
themselves from the audience
that you bring to them--
or sorry, from the attitude
that you bring to them, which is
an attitude of, like, silliness
and vulnerability.
How would you said
that attitude helps
them really understand
and makes them feel good
about themselves?
BRETT DENNEN: Well
thank you, first of all,
for saying it much better
than I attempted to say it.
That is exactly it.
Silliness, vulnerable, openness.
I think like when--
I didn't do it today,
but normally when I perform
with a band, usually always,
solo acoustic as well,
I don't wear shoes
just because I feel more
comfortable barefoot.
So then everybody
here is staring
at my feet, which, you
know, I'm not a foot model
or anything like that.
So here's this tall guy with
red hair who's kind of awkward.
And I dance, and my dance
moves are kind of awkward.
But I'm just trying
to tap into-- I'm
doing it because I'm trying
to, like, harness my inner joy.
I'm just trying to tap into
something to get into it,
to play, to feel and
go to another place
where I'm really not aware of
what is happening with my body.
And I hope that
people look at that
and they see oh,
here's a guy believing
himself-- believing in himself.
He's not-- he doesn't
look like the people
you hear on the radio.
He doesn't sound like the
people you hear on the radio.
But he's up there having
the time of his life
and he's playing good
music and he's singing--
he's tapping into something.
That hopefully makes them
feel good about their own skin
and situation and set of
circumstances, at least
in the moment, and they
can just-- we can all just
have a great time together and
I can feed off of their energy.
And then when they walk
out, they can feel good.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
So I guess music is an
avenue towards, like,
coming out on the other end with
more clarity, in some sense.
And then I guess the question
would be, do you agree?
And if so, what have you
learned about yourself?
BRETT DENNEN: It's a
good point to make,
that you may be-- I may be
going through something,
and I write to try to figure out
what it is I'm going through.
What have I learned about
myself, what sort of clarity
have I gained?
With this most recent
record that I've
made that's yet
to come out, I've
learned that I'm a lot more
sensitive and emotional than I
thought I was.
And the songs that I wrote
for this record came at a time
when I didn't have
a lot of confidence.
And I think it just--
a lot of things,
just where I am in life,
being in my mid-thirties,
where I am in my career,
like wanting more and wanting
to branch-- artistically
wanting to expand.
And I'm always trying to
push myself artistically
to some new territory.
I don't know what it
is or where it is,
but to feel like I'm,
like, onto something,
or like at least
something new for me.
And if I'm not feeling
that way, I'm uninspired,
and I'm learning that I
need to write all the time.
I need to be productive
as an artist.
But I also need to take
care of myself as a person,
emotionally.
That's all I've really learned
with-- so far with this record.
Just things about
myself, I guess.
And I'm lucky to do
it in a fashion that
allows me to have a
career and do what I love.
And hopefully people relate.
Yeah?
Oh yeah, you need it,
because we're broadcasting.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Brett.
I just wanted to know more,
like, superficial question.
I know you're from
San Francisco,
and I was surprised
that you moved
to LA, or to Venice Beach.
BRETT DENNEN: I'm actually
from Oakdale, which
is a couple hours from here.
But if we wanted to see
a concert or something,
we'd come to San Francisco.
And I don't know
if you want to get
me started on that second
half of the question,
because I have this theory
that, like, the north just
always hates on the south.
It's like people in LA
think people in San Diego
are the worst, and then
people in San Francisco
think people in
LA are the worst.
And people in Portland think
that San Francisco-- I don't
know, maybe I'm making this up.
AUDIENCE: Is it better,
like, creatively?
BRETT DENNEN: But
from what I've noticed
from spending a lot of
time in the Bay Area
and from spending a lot
of time in Los Angeles
is people in the Bay Area
always say LA is so this, that.
The people are so
this, that, and that.
And then people in
Los Angeles just say,
it's just cold up there.
There's a lot of good
people in Los Angeles,
and it's one of the most
vibrant cities we have.
And I don't-- I mean, I
don't want to try to convince
everybody that-- I'm
not an ambassador to LA,
but I moved down there to try
to make something happen with
music.
And it did.
And I might have been
able to do that up here.
I might have been able to do
it in Nashville or New York.
But LA has an amazing
mix of culture.
And the weather's incredible.
And the ocean is beautiful.
And all my favorite
music, most of it
came out of Los
Angeles in the '70s.
And I wanted to see if I
could have a part of that.
JAMES DRISCOLL: What
is some of that music?
The Doors?
BRETT DENNEN: The Doors
I'm starting to appreciate.
But I love, like,
Crosby, Stills and Nash.
That's one of the-- and
like that whole scene.
The Eagles and Jackson
Browne and-- there's
different areas in music that
are just completely golden,
and different scenes come
from different towns.
Like you have the British,
like the London in the '60s was
that was it.
And LA in the early
'70s, that was
a special moment in
music that is probably
my favorite era of music.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
First of all, go Banana Slugs.
BRETT DENNEN: All right.
AUDIENCE: My
question is, did you
have a moment or a pivotal point
in your career or your journey
where you were at a
crossroads and you,
like, didn't know to keep
going or do something else?
And if you were,
like, how did you
make the decision to continue
down the path of music?
BRETT DENNEN: I had
one of those recently
when I was-- right before
I was writing this album.
I just felt a little
tapped out and uninspired.
And I was going through
a lot personally.
My girlfriend and I sort
of, like, took a break,
and I felt like taking
a break from music.
But I didn't tell anybody about
it because I felt pressure
because I'm on a
major label now and I
wanted to produce for them
and make everybody happy.
And so I didn't
really deal with it,
I just told everybody
I have some songs.
They're almost done.
And then I just--
I've somehow I worked
through it, just by spending
a lot of time alone writing,
being in the mountains.
When I first started writing
songs, I wasn't-- like,
I was trying to figure out life
by working at a-- I would work
at a summer camp, and then
in the spring and the fall
I'd work at another camp, like
an outdoor ed camp up here.
And then I'd have
big gaps of time
where I didn't know what to do.
I'd go move back
in with my parents.
And when I'd write songs
at that period in my life,
for my first record, it
was kind of like music--
I didn't know anything
about the industry
or what it was like
to be a musician,
I just wanted to be
in the band that I
saw at the local club
that seats 300 people.
I was like, if I could be
that, that's-- I'm set.
I made it.
And so I was writing
songs dreaming of that.
And every time I wrote a song,
it was a thrilling experience
because I'm introducing
myself through music.
And then you start
to do it full-time,
and sometimes
inspiration runs out
and you have to find new ways
to say what you said before
or go down new avenues.
And it's tough to keep it going.
And sometimes, if you
don't feel inspired
and what you have to do
requires inspiration,
it's hard to separate
yourself from your music
or from your art.
And it can lead to a really deep
rut that you can't get out of.
But a piece of music
or a concert you go see
or something can, like,
just make everything
feel good again.
AUDIENCE: Will you come through
Santa Cruz on your next tour?
BRETT DENNEN: We are
planning a tour right now,
and I don't think we
have Santa Cruz in there.
But I will eventually, probably
in the fall at the soonest.
JAMES DRISCOLL: I think we have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
That's me.
So I, first of
all, I learned how
to play guitar and, like,
singing and start playing
music from your music.
So I think, like, my
first Starbucks show ever,
I did, like, a bunch
of your covers.
So this is like awesome
that I'm here right now.
But we kind of just
talked about how
you make people feel
kind of like vulnerable
and tap into their emotions.
And I think part of that
is, like, your lyrics are
so personal.
And I just-- maybe
this comes easy to you,
but if you have any
advice for those of us
who it doesn't, like
sometimes when I write music,
I'm worried to, like, be
so exposed to everyone,
like, with-- it's, like,
your most inner thoughts.
Like, do you have any advice
on how to get past that?
BRETT DENNEN: Something
I learned recently
that was really
hard for me to admit
is that most people, when
they listen to music,
the lyrics don't matter.
And if they do matter, they
come second to the music.
And that was hard
for me to swallow,
because I spent so much
time slaving over lyrics.
And you can have an
amazing lyric that's
put to mediocre music,
and you put that up
against amazing music
with a mediocre lyric,
and that will win.
The music always
wins, because music
has a certain magic that you
can't grab or hold or feel.
It just gets into-- it unlocks
memories and reminds you
of things and gets
inside your heart
and stirs your emotions up.
Lyrics can do the same
thing, but the music does it
on-- in a different way.
So the point is, don't beat
yourself up over it too much.
Just make sure it's honest.
Doesn't have to be honest,
but if you're-- you sound like
someone who really wants
to say something truthful.
Then just be honest.
And if you really
want to be honest
and you want to say
something from the heart
but you don't know how to
say it, I think you do,
you just aren't giving
yourself permission,
or you're not
digging deep enough,
or there's something that
you know you want to say
but maybe you're
afraid to say it.
And I'm projecting
on you right now,
because that's what
always works for me.
If there's something
I'm afraid to say,
it is the most
meaningful to sing.
And it doesn't have to rhyme.
It doesn't have to--
there's no rules.
It just-- as long
as it's authentic.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Thank you.
On that note, I think--
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for being here.
BRETT DENNEN: Yep.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Thank you for
sharing your music with us
today.
[APPLAUSE]